today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza get
that hitter today's episode is also
brought to you by blue chew if you like
sex well put a little bit in your mouth
blue chew is a performance enhancement
for the bedroom wouldn't you like to
last longer and go extra rounds I
personally wouldn't but I'm lazy blue
chewed calm makes the first chewable
with same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis and at a lower price than
those other two chewables work faster
than pills up to twice as fast Oh what
are you chewing on the opportunity to
[ __ ] that's what it only takes a few
minutes to fill out a form online no
doctor's visits no awkward conversations
oh hey
oh I'm just eating these dick pills no
waiting in line at a pharmacy what are
you here for toilet paper what are you
here for
[ __ ] ability this ships directly to your
door and a discreet packaging could be
anything could be a javelin could be a
microwave it could be blue Chu Lu Chu
gives you confidence in bed every time
you and your partner will love it and
here's a great deal for you guys visit
blue Chu calm and get your first order
free when you use promo code Theo just
pay $5 shipping that's B lu e CH e w
calm and promo code theo
chu away and now let's get into our
episode today's guest is a man that has
inspired me in my line of work since he
got here or since i got here
since i met him that's when and he is
the popular host of one of my favorite
podcast called the fighter and the kid
one of the first podcast i was ever a
guest on and he's always been supportive
he's absolutely hilarious he has a new
special out right now called complicated
apes which he says is his best work but
more importantly than all of that in a
time when states are really starting to
take back their stronghold
from unified America we decided to have
a March Madness where every state is up
against every other state in an all-out
war we've built the brackets on the back
of our producer Nick Davis we got little
Gianni in here to freaking giggle in the
distance we put together a March Madness
this past weekend state Wars bracket and
who better to help us break down the
games and advance that the states
forward then the just really one of the
smartest guys I know but I don't know
that many people mr. Brian Talent do you
think there's gonna come a time where
there's that cutoff line and I was just
talking to Joe about this the other
night where there's a cutoff line where
there's people that can live forever and
there's people that can yeah and there's
gonna be well cuz money money will be
the delineating fact oh wow when you can
download when you can get a chip and you
can download certain things in your
brain you'll buy the software to learn
how to fly a helicopter or to get to get
your black belt in jujitsu yeah that's a
fact and the more money you have the
more skills you'll have but then the
question becomes to what end
it I wonder how fun it is when you have
that skill base and you can speak a
language fluently whatever that language
might be right but but you didn't work
for it yeah he didn't work for it but
you have that understanding I'm not sure
I'm not so sure I wonder what kind of
benefit you get from that like do you do
you glean the same kind of satisfaction
because it takes a long time to be good
at something yeah do you have any like
we had an understanding you develop
understanding from from practice yeah
you get you develop understanding from
spending a long time at something you
understand like you know what I mean
well that's because you're young my son
that comes into my lap yeah oh yeah
that's that class action laps who have
gotten a couple of emails about it
exactly right um but no that said yes
like if everything just becomes it's
almost like a universal basic income
idea it's like if everybody has it is
there any value are you gonna care
you're just gonna put the Spanish chip
in when you get [ __ ] up to be at a
party I'm Spanish yeah well you have the
jackal Willick buck here and so why do
you like chocolate look you go well the
guy was he's a black belt in jujitsu
sometimes he taps Dean Lister so he's
really good at that he worked really
hard at that the art and and intricate
system of jujitsu oh yeah and got
downloaded enough of the the moves and
stuff to be able to kind of cut you off
before you make your move whatever he's
strategic that way we also know he's a
tank he's 240 pounds he's the San Diego
double dragon the double dragon I like
that and you can't double leg him
because his legs are tree trunks but
then also he was a seal they found out
how older and in one of his legs the
other day I believe it yes I would out
it was endangered spotted yeah man so so
you you respect the guy like that cuz
he's got scars because he's gone through
some [ __ ] his skin's a little thicker oh
yeah you know what I mean so you go
yeah his ears look broken up and that's
attractive for a human being who's been
through the fire a baptism of fire you
find yourself drawn to that yeah because
they have wisdom you don't know why
that's why you got into it for advice
but not the 21 year old who's nothing
yes it's been easy for yes I'm [ __ ] a
little stem cell junkie yeah some guy
just [ __ ] hanging out on his own
blood yeah beautify were 21 I'd be up
all night your can off in a moan mouth
these days honestly and not a message
anyway you know what mouth my own well
you can get I think you can trace you
know think about that you'll get what
you can get blood transfusions from
young people they do that right see
that's what I think it's gonna be that's
gonna be that line I think they young
like you're saying it's gonna be money I
think it's gonna be farming the young
there yeah well I think that that the
one thing man has always wanted what's
the one thing man's always wanted what's
the one thing man loves this is from
Socrates horse it is good clothes plus I
like that and we do like horses but we
use them as tools yeah what is the one
man universally everywhere wants women
no what do you think it is contentment
no it's to live forever it's in
mortality yes why we love our children
they push our genes forward it's why we
love our work because we leave a legacy
behind man does whatever he can to leave
a mark that's why being significant
especially for males being significant
is so [ __ ] important and whenever you
compare yourself like you get depressed
and you go I don't know I feel like a we
work harder because you don't feel like
you're significant you're not doing
anything that makes you feel like an you
leave in a mark that sometimes I don't
know if that's true but sometimes that
could be the case you want to lose a
good book I've read that but um there's
all that [ __ ] that that kind of um that
comes into it so immortality we've
always wanted to live forever so now
with new longevity drugs and technology
holy [ __ ] it's on the road yeah that's
what it is but then what you know what I
like about living forever if you told me
at 50 I was gonna have the same energy
as a 21 20 year old which I do yeah
which I [ __ ] do oh your Fitbit did it
the other day just [ __ ] blew right
off your shoe off my wrist bro you saw
that right yeah I don't run a sprint
yeah all right and a lot of times I run
with sand yeah two buckets of sand and a
bamboo pole over my [ __ ] back and I
run hills you [ __ ] somebody said you
had four shoulder blades is that true no
it's not true it just looks that way cuz
I got I got muscle on top a muscle I'm
the first comedian to develop muscle on
top you understand that's why the doctor
goes I got nothing to say oh yeah who
wrote on my chart immortal I don't know
if that's good yeah that's good but he
looked at my blood panel and goes well
guess you're never gonna die oh you're
that hemoglobin bad boy that's what it
is that's why you could sell my plasma
on the black market for as much as rhino
horn goes for you know what I'm saying
Jesus Christ man people getting into
that hell yeah I could cut a diamond
with my deck right now damn there and we
can do that yeah I stretch up and I know
whatever baby this is [ __ ]
okay we
have you here today Brian obviously
thank you so much for always having me
on fighter in the kid and for you guys
always original so we were talking about
me and Brogan we're talking about you
yesterday that's nice we were talking
about how great you are as a comic you
we were talking about you and who the
[ __ ] else were we talking about
about being truly unique voices that was
me that was your older peers that was
two fifty two year olds talking about
you young man so bow the [ __ ] down and
you're welcome thank you on Rogen thank
you giving you now serious props I don't
even know it so I don't want to see you
beat yourself up all right back to
you'll do that myself up back to you
thank you we need somebody who's
educated bro and we looked across the
field of comedians and tough to find
there was just you really it's a
wasteland
you know me I'm tough Davidoff
everything else to [ __ ] waste yeah
and of David all who we can't you know
got to know a special mating call to
even get him a show well yes sir he's
he's hiding he's doing he's doing real
estate deals he's a he's a real estate
mogul he can give a [ __ ] about
everything oh yeah and on the 30th floor
of his dreams right yes and you and I
are down here [ __ ] around but we need
somebody who's educated it's March
Madness so we and I firmly believe we're
headed back towards state governments
you know cuz states are so different
yeah that in in five years ten years we
could see states
you know just build on their own kind of
walls or just delineating their own
things that fit for their people so we
want a March Madness if these states
went at it who would win and we want to
get to the Final Four we're gonna go
through at least the first out around
today okay and and let's start Nick is
gonna be our referee and that was the
selection committee as well that's why
some of these states got buys but yeah
okay okay what were the vibe a ston
population the fur we split up the
region's into West Midwest south and
east and in each region the top for
roughly populations got to buy sometimes
it was a little different so we kept
some matchups we had to see in the first
round like North Dakota South Dakota the
North North Carolina South Carolina we
really want to see those if we would
have so there was some some liberties
taken by the select
committee but here we are okay finally
okay cool so let's start with that
person's own doubt oh dude I was looking
at that poster but I love that that
painting that road to the strap goes
through the rat yeah man you got [ __ ]
you guys made the belt man I like that
man that's only for consent wrap up word
up the river broke after that he put his
gum under the table he put all of his
ideas into a piece of gum and just as
well he should if you need Rappaport
he's in the back of my sock all right
okay so where we start Nick let's raw
let's start in the upper left here the
Midwest number 5
Wisconsin verse number 12 Minnesota okay
in a war yes okay here's the thing
yep I'm going with Minnesota couple
reasons they're both basically the same
people
the difference is Wisconsin's got a lot
of Irish and a lot of other things a lot
of whiskey going on a lot of cheese and
a lot of junk food so they're not moving
as quickly yep Minnesota's landing of
the Giants if you know anything about
the history of Minnesota the people from
Scandinavia especially Norwegians a lot
of Swedes settled up there now they they
take to wheat and they take to milk and
they take to farm and write good yep and
they they're not afraid of those cold
winter sort of Minnesota winters on top
of the fact that they're super organized
why cuz they're an agrarian people yeah
and you're not ready for the winter and
you don't have a sense of time and
organization if you don't understand how
to [ __ ] and follow rules which means
march in lockstep lock and load when
you're told to and let loose when you're
told to if though if the cold does not
bother them and they've got big
Scandinavian hands that can hold swords
and guns and clubs and whatever else
they need yeah and they can carry a lot
of provisions yep cereal that's correct
sweet and they and they do well on
cereal there's no gluten intolerance up
there no they live on meat and wheat and
potatoes Minnesotans [ __ ] oh and by the
way gays to you you wanted a lot of game
in there and women it'll survive a
winter we're not talking about these
summer no no no there's no dancing there
no no no movement in the hip it's a no
Billy Elliot boy this is Willie this is
William Illya they walk from the from
the shoulders they walk
bears now here's the other thing you
don't know about Minnesota all right
Wisconsin those winters are brutal
Minnesota has has some food that grows
out there in the water you know what
that is I know what it is rice goddamn
right Wow so wild rice and now you
starvin but don't worry about that cuz
you go and you go and rake that those
ponds and now you got a bucket full of
rice you can swim with your mouth open
rice is a correct sir you can swim with
your mouth open
rice is a fantastic carbohydrate keeps
you going in battle Minnesota all day
against Wisconsin in a war wisconsin has
police they have a lot of policemen
they're my dad's from Wisconsin is
equally a policeman wanna race in
Milwaukee so I got respect right but my
dad's a tough guy but he's got too much
Irish got German and Irish but mostly
Irish too slow moves it moves like
Frankenstein built like Frankenstein -
yeah he doesn't have that Norwegian you
know my reasons tend to be more VD out
yes in easy bone structures oh they can
sleep with their eyes open a lot of
these people let's go to what we had a
video submission for someone who has an
insight good what up Theo so I think
Wisconsin would definitely win in a war
just because we've got a ton of serial
killers man we've got we had at least
Jeffrey Dahmer we have Steven Avery we
got that smiley face killer indeed we
also have Badgers you put a badger on a
leash you send that thing after someone
you're screwed man Minnesota's badgers -
[ __ ] - yeah I think Wisconsin
definitely win max laughing hey man
those are good points there are good
points
serial killers aren't you can't control
them and they end up killing their own
troops
here's the probables they wake up at
night and they see all their all their
buddies sleeping yeah all they see is
throats waiting to be slit oh yeah and I
can't help but so the next thing you
know Jeffrey Dahmer's eaten everybody
and cut everybody's throat yeah he kind
of is throat and you catch from drinking
everybody's blood you like dude you just
killed your entire [ __ ] platoon he's
like sorry I couldn't help ya didn't do
it like god damnit shoot him right now
yeah and by that time my Minnesotans
have moved in yep Wisconsin you have Ron
Dayne and Nick Davis's from there what
do you have Nick that guy mentioned the
smiley face killer yeah that's just a
weird conspiracy because in my hometown
all across Wisconsin over the past 10 to
15 years 10 to 15
drunk college guys have just wandered
into the river and ended up drowning and
now there's like documentaries on Annie
is it uh is it a killer dragging but
it's all [ __ ] it's it's you're from
La Crosse Wisconsin
yes sir is that where La Crosse was
invented because it was a Native
American invention
it was definitely yeah it was Native
American land and it's actually a place
where three rivers meet so a tornado
will never touch down a triumvirate Wow
nope you call it lacrosse mm-hmm that
means the cross mm-hmm huh lacrosse
Lacroix la Lacroix of course I think
means in French the cross and I speak
French
okay keep going okay I you know what I
think if I had any thoughts on that I
think you even just said it people are
drunk wandering in the rivers when this
must be learning yeah that's a huge
juxtaposition right there bro you're
here to learn and you [ __ ] can't even
learn a set of a river when you've been
drinking bro I'm killing drunk people
see who wins in a War Between the States
everybody chimed in 52% Wow it was
neck-and-neck there Minnesota I think
gets the nod guys sorry Nick all right I
did I did live in Minnesota for eight
years and went to university Minnesota
so oh there you go oh god we got
Kentucky Missouri next we're actually
we're gonna move to announce thoughts on
that okay yeah let's do it do it well I
mean Missouri Missouri is all good but
see Missouri is basically it's kind of
like a state you forget about all due
respect yeah unless you like Mark Twain
it's kind of a state when you think of
Missouri you think about wide-open
fields
you don't think about a lot of people
you think about people spaced out st.
Louis do where they shot that kid
terrible town might be the worst town in
the world actually pretty true
yeah and bad yeah and and and there is
there's a lot of racial division there
oh you're not gonna get you're not gonna
get black people to be like hey come
fight our war they're gonna be like I
got my own war to deal with no I don't
want to support you you haven't been
supporting me so kiss my ass you know
that got off nine people by this
Hardee's over here already yeah man
they've been in a war so [ __ ] and easy
so Missouri's just not organized now
here's the thing about Kentucky oh yeah
now Kentucky's where the Hatfields and
McCoys come from don't forget that
Kentucky is where it was settled by the
by that by the Highlanders of northern
Oh bye-bye shepherds which comes from an
honor culture you solve your problems
with violence
Kentucky was basically in a low-grade
Civil War I mean the Hatfields and
McCoys came from Kentucky yeah you had a
good chance of getting killed in
Kentucky if you came from somewhere else
if you weren't polite god help you if
you got it on with another man's woman
oh my god because you solved your
problems with a knife for a gun and that
goes back to the beginning of our
country in Kentucky beginning of time in
those [ __ ] hills and the hills of
Kentucky you want it you want to you
want to get yourself a big old army yeah
everybody has guns yeah they can't
[ __ ] wait and all they need is a
common enemy to get together yeah cuz
when you're from Kentucky everybody else
is from somewhere else yeah you know
what they say Kentucky can [ __ ] you up
that's what they say now keep in mind
they are they always have some whiskey
in their body and a good point man you
know from the south
yeah but Missouri Missouri they're a
little more god-fearing you see Kentucky
God doesn't touch down he does they'll
go to charity Anders they'll go to
church but it's a little bit like taking
a stone and dropping it in the well yeah
you can keep that stone and the well for
as long as you want when you break that
stone open water is only on the outside
amen you understand yeah yeah I
understand yeah God doesn't much
permeate into the hillbillies yeah into
the bill Hillbillies Hart
yeah the lonner honor territory honorary
honor and loyalty yeah loyalty to your
family in your clan oh so do not [ __ ]
with people in Kentucky because they
will fight you right now and by the way
they have at least 25 kids it's it I
mean every kid short kids they put them
on each other and just give them a long
gun for this yeah man so you're fighting
entire families bro and you know you
fight for your family yeah so Missouri
doesn't have a [ __ ] chance
in fact Kentucky goes to war with
Missouri and Missouri becomes Kentucky
Missouri just disappeared that's it so
it's a hundred to zero in my book I'm
gonna say again I was in East st. Louis
and there was a Ramada and while I was
there it got taken over by I don't even
what it was tokens I mean it could have
been anything ah if you hear a lot of
that the way I don't know in the morning
suddenly there was just a bunch of
people working at the front desk they
didn't even work there he's [ __ ] very
dead that's home of the hillbilly home
of the hillbilly I would have to say
Kentucky to on that one man and then the
WoW the listeners agree 72% won Kentucky
but Missouri is that river access man
well that's you so with river access you
can ship mercenaries in but mercenaries
are never loyal Kentucky just turn
around and go hey guys don't have much
money but I got all the whiskey all the
moonshine you need that's true those
mercenaries are like [ __ ] this I want to
drink and [ __ ] we got hot women we got
hard horses dude you want to watch them
[ __ ] it's two bucks there you go you
know here you go man what am watch them
fight it's for mm-hmm that's right girls
we'll take it for the team too Oh a lot
of tall women there too listen I've had
I've had some good times in Kentucky
yeah I know that they got the best
bourbon in the world mm-hmm and I've had
some I've had some good times in
Kentucky damn damn oh you seem like now
watch how my voice goes now now listen
up I've had some good times you ask me
how Wow how good a time ask me ask me
what I did would you do in Kentucky
buddy stay busy stay busy well you been
eating gravel oh yeah little bit hey I
got a special place in my heart for
Kentucky I can hear ya sometimes I
caught ya cuz I'm a [ __ ] crazy fool oh
yeah you understand oh what's that in
those heels oh that's yeah yeah Kentucky
I secretly say that in my among my
friends yeah I know nobody's listening
right now so I can say this to you oh
this is safe as we knew me I'd say
that's it
Kentucky Kentucky yeah he's gonna uh
he's gonna hunt their way right into
this guy god-fearing girls only on
Sunday though oh yeah many on in church
oh they got that chick-fil-a plus it's
correct you know and it's correct
Kentucky if things only open six days a
week
you know mmm better shut it down and put
pickles on it yeah damn but I don't have
any teeth don't you worry about that
yeah daddy didn't give a [ __ ] about
teeth
yeah that's gay I'm kidding I've seen
some beautiful woman
and the men not feel like coming a
little bit the women are really the
prize over there women are the women can
fight in Kentucky oh yeah and the men
can too and they will the men sniff the
air is not talking yeah the men in
Kentucky will go yeah there you're
raised to to go you understand well
that's the instinct bill oh yeah now let
me see it let me tell you what a man in
Kentucky does yeah when you come at him
mm-hmm you meet you halfway
oh Jesus understand yeah you don't need
to go all the way there he's all easy
I'm meet halfway
Jesus all right and it's just out of
it's out of kindness your place I've
ever had a guy try to fight me for no
reason
Wow yeah and by the way I was ready I
was in a threesome one time in Indiana
really yeah how was that uh it wasn't
that great one girl pretty cool her
friend not cool not very attractive you
know not that that matters but it also
matters and she look kind of looked like
remember back in like vaudeville the
vaudeville weightlifters like those
people are where the one-strap and the
thing in a set of thousand per kilograms
on it you know she looked like that like
that old-school body you know
well my she was on the side of the bed
doing [ __ ] like I don't know what she
was doing burpies or something while me
and the one girl where I'm in sex and
they didn't even really know each other
that good yeah they were also trying to
get to know each other it was [ __ ]
awkward friend had a scale and I one of
those cool scales where you can measure
somebody's height hmm he brought a girl
home he's a big guy played football and
she was thick oh yeah thick thick and I
respect a man who's not afraid if
someone was thick he put her on that
scale and he called me up next day and
he said she came in at 5-3 184 and she
looked up at me and I looked at her and
I said those numbers are not good I'm
still attracted Wow
so I appreciate that he went back in
four seconds I'm appreciate that in a
man
oh yeah sorry anyway that's that golden
so now we now we got Oregon Idaho in
Montana
that's like when your van breaks down
outside of a Golden Corral you got to
eat there a couple times you know mmm or
are there any other first round matchups
that you really have a strong
inclination on uh you talking about Oh
Iowa Nebraska
let's go there well now now now listen
man this is a tough one
very got good wrestlers you got good
wrestlers and tough farm boys out of
both places
oh damn do you ever you might have to go
I'll tell you how you make this decision
Iowa Nebraska very simple now I went to
wrestling camp in Iowa oh man Gables
camp oh yeah Dave Gable was a champ
hardest thing I've ever done in my life
all right realize that if that was what
d1 wrestling was I didn't have it you
were d8 and I didn't want to I was da
brother yeah I'm an actor yeah I was
crazy did I go back to my high school
and crush it crush everybody my senior
year did I lose only once yeah I think
that's I think that's probably true yes
I think I lost only once but a black guy
over the high school wrestler this is
not about me
no he was a he was a white now-now-now
um no but Iowa I always got some crazy
tough people in Nebraska and Iowa I need
to see this is how you make this
decision I need to see who has the
bigger population Wow and whoever has
the bigger population is who you go with
in a war but I want to also know with
the land elevation of both can we look
into both of those now I like your I
like that you know why because when you
got higher level elevation you got
better wind yeah so I'm enjoying that so
so Iowa has way more people you go with
Iowa 100% they got over a million more
people Wow
so of course it's Iowa sorry to
interrupt this state fight but I have to
ask is there something that interferes
with your happiness or that is
preventing you from achieving your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you better help offers
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
stress anxiety anger grief oh I had them
all up until grief I think self esteem
and more connect with your professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment anything you share is
confidential and it's so convenient I've
used better hell and I found it to work
for me get help at your own time and at
your own pace
you can schedule secure video or phones
Plus chat and text with your therapist I
had a moment where I was I had to go to
an event and and I just wasn't feeling
great and I was able to set up an
appointment with my therapist actually
pull over on the side of the road and
have a FaceTime conversation with them
so it better help really can facilitate
these different options if you're not
happy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time best of
all is truly affordable and this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month with discount code Theo von no
spaces th e o vo in that's right get
started if you need help go to better
help calm slash Theo von now if you have
a therapist and that's working for you
then stick with that and if you don't
need help
and you're doing great then that's
awesome help others but if you do need
help I just wanted you to know that
better help is an option simply fill out
a questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get matched up with a
counselor you'll love that's better help
calm slash Theo von and now back to the
Anarchy population alone yeah you gotta
go you gotta go Iowa if we go population
for all the matchups it's gonna be a
quick quick March Madness so right but
it's not even that might have been a bad
yeah and so I'm only using population in
this instance because they're so similar
they're so similar I don't give a [ __ ]
how much how many people misery could
have all the people Kentucky still
kicking their ass well here's the thing
if yeah if you were in Iowa they got the
same stuff Nebraska's got you know
except people in Iowa say they're in
Iowa and people in Nebraska say they're
in Nebraska mm-hmm that's the only
differences what happened there Oh Iowa
41 Nebraska Wow 59 we have the
Cornhuskers you have the hawk I see more
Hawks in Iowa yeah she can have more
things you know that arable teams more
winnings oh I don't know you got BJ
Armstrong came out of Iowa yeah you got
some tough kids from Iowa boy but
Nebraska dude it's got Braska corn-fed
corn-fed boys core yeah of course not
good for it spikes your insulin that's
true actually she got a bunch of
diabetics over there who yeah who's got
the gout
oh do when you get [ __ ] milo and i
will you give milo when you're [ __ ]
elbows it's a
now you need he needs to go with Iowa
that that's that's wrong
yeah well Rock Iowa there all right yeah
that's because a million more people's a
lot oh [ __ ] yeah that's a lot it's a lot
yeah let's round out the first round in
the Midwest North Dakota versus South
Dakota well one of them as the black
hills pop I think you go North Dakota
because they're colder and people from
colder climates are a little more Hardy
they are also closer to Canada though so
they're more polite yeah so they say
sorry after they punch you probably you
know there's some canady some Canada
juice rolled into the North Dakotans
oh yeah a little bit of that seeping
down a little bit yeah soft syrup that
simple syrup they call it dude we had
regular syrup then we went up to Canada
and got a little simple around there
yeah we're the badlands
you got itself the badlands yeah or I
think they are you go north Dakota
yeah you don't get a name like that from
just [ __ ] having regular lands mother
these bad these lands have [ __ ] been
an after-school detention correct sir
bad man South Dakota Wow I'm goin I'm
goin South Dakota yeah cuz I could see
some of that you know that kindness from
Canada slipping in yeah you got South
Dakota right there the badlands Jesse
James was from there just Jackson yeah
yeah Jesse the guy that was on The
Bachelor how small that
yeah just his mullet he was from there
if you ask Justin yes yeah they're all
from that area yeah dude that's the
misspelling [ __ ] you give a [ __ ] how
their spells a tail I'll do whatever
they got to do to [ __ ] you up
ya know fake an injury and sue I'll do
whatever they have to do yeah and one of
them's no Dakota and when I'm so Dakota
you go
so Dakota yeah so Dakota alright the
first round in the Midwest look over to
the quickly a state can fall it's
amazing to see that it's amazing to say
and this is what it's like bro even at a
government level it's a couple of [ __ ]
moonbeams sitting around on top of Eddie
Bravo's [ __ ] darkest dreams just
pointing fingers and aside and who does
what man you're right that's all that's
right Maryland Delaware look into it
we're in the East well [ __ ] I mean is
Delaware really a stable
I mean I know it is but I've driven
through Delaware it took me five minutes
to drive through yeah
like Delaware tailwind yeah the thing is
Delaware could be just taken over by
Maryland and you would never notice so I
don't know if I'm even I think Delaware
Delaware is more of a province of
Maryland yeah they call it a honky
Puerto Rico to Delhi with Delaware's
barely silverware Delaware it's
something really named after much I feel
like we got it we got it we got it
somebody live on the Maryland would
easily win the state we're broke we got
Michael Phelps most athletic guy in the
world
we always die Louis he murdered someone
once and got away with that bro he'll do
it again
yep we also have the white house is in
Maryland now Trump will new every single
state that tries to [ __ ] with us we
literally cannot lose period hey your
hey hey you [ __ ] dummy hey my team's
not the most athletic person in the
world and and [ __ ] how dare you say
the white house is in Maryland you
non-american get that ISIS plant off
that screen don't ever bring that guy up
again well this is I've never said it
haha [ __ ] do you do a video lying there
like a looking all cuddly and cozy oh
this is you and you were young we got
this out of a time capsule in high
school yeah Delaware so ideal world just
kind of hide hiding in the corner
somewhere like under a table and then
when when it goes clear they pop out
he makes a point that couples wash wits
where's the captain said that why is his
right hand all curled up on his chest
like a little polio man if they got
polio in Delaware dude he's holding the
hankie or his little silk piece of silk
cloth his mom gave him probably the guy
was only this big
he's about that big yeah he's got a
little blankie a little baby Marilyn you
have Baltimore the opioid epidemic if
the it's the wrong ones Baltimore alone
like a walking zombie and they got guns
to enforce the law dude do it
you got lobstering guns Baltimore alone
you get those gangsters in Baltimore and
they'll take over Delaware they will
annex Delaware but you get a couple
sisters hopped up on some [ __ ] lump
crab and give him a [ __ ] grenade
bishop so no chips and nails oh yeah so
I think that's an easy one for me man
Delaware good luck um but also
silverware Delaware your product
hardware you're not even I agree bro
they barely got you in correct but god
bless you guys
Connecticut and Rhode Island um
Connecticut as Hills Maine Connecticut
is basically Britain it's like a Little
Britain yeah here's the thing about
Rhode Island people don't realize
Providence Rhode Island's the last
gangster town province Rylan is so mafia
heavy and so so heavily run by the Mafia
Rhode Island can get any kind of
weaponry they want yeah now Connecticut
may have a couple pistolas Rhode Island
Trevor Shea's they've a trebuchet so
they got a trebuchet yeah which is a
fancy word for catapult thank you for
the for the French you bet
do you like it trebuchet cuz you Cajun
I got a little bit man we had this
little trepidation you put it in front
and just shoot a little bit a dessert in
your mouth
correct they got trebuchet see they can
get grenade launchers they put a bomb in
your car also they kill the entire so
Connecticut has their generals in their
upper brass Rhode Island just puts a hit
on all them they blow them all up on
their cars so Rhode Island is mafia
Providence alone you're not getting into
Providence because they run it from
Providence the Mafia you're fighting the
Mafia they fight dirty they already got
inroads they already got your house
bugged they already got your [ __ ] car
your stove all they have a lot of stone
walls about everything they know
everything about you before anything
they they you're done you're done you
got water access what about Hartford
though Hartford ad doesn't matter hard
for just a bigger the Harford's about
insurance
yeah it's insured kinetics is gonna need
insurance after Rhode Island's done with
it I go with Rhode Island all [ __ ]
day Connecticut's one big forest anyway
I used to live there yeah I saw deer and
forests and ticks is it yeah Oh God
yeah I saw a guy get bit by a dog and
[ __ ] Providence dude and uh and yeah
it seemed dangerous dude not a lot of
street lights I would go dogs everywhere
no stray dogs pax astray crazy dogs dude
and there's a dark dog underworld over
there to do babies never my yeah oh yeah
I'll go with Providence bad boy Rhode
Island I'm good there there you go sweet
West Virginia Vermont not even a
question
Yanis West Virginia just been rednecks
will take Vermont Vermont is the home of
Bernie Sanders bidding varies though
exactly we Ben and Jerry's weed and
they're socialists driving a Volkswagen
listening to the Grateful Dead pumpkin
pie the whole [ __ ] nine yeah they are
too high and too liberal to do anything
I could go in and take over Vermont
alone I could beat up that whole [ __ ]
thing I need a small club and I don't
know a piece of meat because they'd run
from I would love that movie Bryan
Callen versus Vermont you gotta beat
them all up I'll beat that whole state
up well [ __ ] that place I like Vermont
but [ __ ] it it was well it's too liberal
for me and [ __ ] Bernie Sanders there I
said it
[ __ ] socialist he went to the Soviet
Union on his honeymoon did he die yes
[ __ ] that guy okay that guy's not an
American he's a communist so kiss my ass
he's a closet communist and so are all
Vermont ins all right why the way I've
been skiing at all I lived I went to
high school up there I know Vermont very
well my sister went to Burlington my
first love was from Burlington from Lake
Champlain the whole [ __ ] nine yards I
know all about UVM that liberal besides
race
holy [ __ ] are they liberal too liberal
too progressive
go [ __ ] yourself not a gun to be found
that whole state yeah I know there are
people out there that are you know
they're there they're farmers out there
even the farmers to hate each other
they're like hey hey
that's how the time asked me a question
that ends in yes where I gotta say yes
oh man do you have a lot of different
senior diseases hang out so it takes
that long to say yes all their [ __ ] are
you locked and loaded hey by the time
you're dead and so that West Virginia
those [ __ ] those rednecks in West
Virginia they they come into Vermont and
they you're done you're [ __ ] done yeah
everybody has a gun in West Virginia
they shoot at planes oh yeah they had
this somebody yeah there you go 74
percent Wow
over twenty six percent [ __ ]
humanity is spoken dude me West Virginia
West Virginia and Vermont and everybody
doesn't smell it a little it doesn't go
my god you get sight you got a citation
for polluting the air yeah that's crazy
man my god the People's Republic of
Vermont you're out of your mind the
Catamounts [ __ ] man they had that good
coach and they [ __ ] let him go they
got statues to Lenin yeah if they want
to bring back the Soviet Union little
new Leningrad
well that well yeah flat Amir Lenin who
was essentially the fellow
[ __ ] that debt left shrimp maybe bro but
nobody else rose as far [ __ ] four and
as I go who's next buddy
New Hampshire verse Maine to close out
the East now Maine I'm gonna start out
with Maine bro you got first of all you
got a lot of celebrity money living off
the coast I'm there Kirstie Alley has a
summer there John Travolta sneaks up
there with young men from the mainland
you got a lot of you got Goonies out
there well [ __ ] you got whaling you
got Willis with you oh that's where the
Whalers Oh Whalers the people you whale
they come from Maine that's a Harley
stock they got the Black Bears of main
main main all day 60 different berries
that will [ __ ] kill and they got the
coast rather they got they got they got
that's the scene where they have Rock
beaches there's pictures of people
laying on [ __ ] sharp beaches in the
summit Maine all day they got access to
the sea everybody
a navy yeah and they can shoot over
their own state and into Maine with
those hella what does [ __ ] submarines
they got dude and first of all how do
you even get to Maine
you know harder it's gonna be to get
there to fight them yeah you can't do it
New Hampshire though bro what where yeah
six people of New Hampshire people I
used to go to again I spent my summers
in New Hampshire
yes how'd you were everywhere I was I
was in I went to summer camp up in Lake
Winnipesaukee oh it sounds like that
that probably something you could drink
out of it again another progressive
state another state that's so clean is
ridiculous but you're clean as Lakes
Allah I grew up next to that
tuberculosis sipper did you funk the
river baby that's what I'm talking about
by the way the people agree 64% oh yeah
when you grew up you can you jump in
that water you can have cash chlamydia
oh do my buddy jumped in bro he got out
he was four years older I believed it
for years [ __ ] old STD and you got
eye infections for the rest of your life
oh yeah how's your eye better right it's
okay dude but can you get pinkeye from
your own butt or not probably mm-hmm
we'll look it up after this
you can't be making around here in your
button I wasn't right I wasn't now so
that does it for the East region first
round some interesting matchups in a
second and a little Gianni over here
who's a [ __ ] and he's gonna be in a
movie with Olivia smart coming along
actually is that right yeah you an actor
yes sorry the black Olivia smart yeah
are you in are you in my special
complicated Apes that's now everywhere
you can rent or buy oh yeah oh good it's
Johnny and complicated apes number one I
number one album on iTunes right I love
the fact that we call him Johnny - now
that's [ __ ] good but that you know
they spell ovaries from Ranji ia in in
hi Oh Johnny you're Italian you're from
Rhode Island yeah there you go
so you know you know about Providence
rich but I look at the stem cells and
that little mother [ __ ] kid with a
full mouth just to feel better right I'm
right oh you're a wrestling everything I
do boxing you do boxing yeah I played I
played hockey growing up a lot like for
probably eighteen forty bucks I box and
burn and Brian Wood would tell you you
don't do any scoring a little bit not
much cuz I'm a nice with Brentwood
Schaub over there he goes in the morning
come over the glove works gets
Papa Papa counting your patterns are
about see if you fall for certain things
I'm not gonna beat I'm not gonna I'm not
I'm gonna mark you up a little bit I'm
not gonna hurt you but I'm let you know
I'll let you know that's all Judy's
favorite patterns Burberry bro this guy
is no [ __ ] dude first of all when
you're skating on [ __ ] water when
there's people who have no water correct
you put on some numbers bro I have my
ways no I'm talking about you putting up
some novices this him let me see how he
punches you put on nervous all right
Tommy go get that [ __ ] aids got some
speed but I'm I'm not liking where your
hand is when you're throwing I'm I see
too much of an opening yeah but come
right at you there oh my cast head all
right good you Catholic athletic weights
on your on your front foot a little bit
too much that's I like the way you're
leaning forward there but that's all
right
yeah Dustin Poirier would beat your ass
though he might he might but the kids
athletic yeah he's good made he got a
strong upper body so if he ends up in a
wheelchair he's not a [ __ ] he's not a
[ __ ] you were a hockey player yeah yeah
you're an athlete all right I appreciate
that dude it's easy to get around when
you can slide on the surface yeah what
sport did you I want to know what sports
do you play growing up basketball and I
was outdoors all the time actually dunk
I could at one time that's pretty
impressive
thanks man got that tail piece that's
why yeah it was all a sprawl they called
me the [ __ ] the flying ass yeah she'd
meet hitting the air she God way pink I
was my [ __ ] defense i watch his ass
that's white [ __ ] they got my eyes all
right let's move on to the South Region
bro come on man this one's gonna get
sticky cuz you got a lot of mmm you got
a lot of quarters all in the air you got
a lot of testosterone yeah I get a lot
of ropeburn
yeah mama style Virginia Tennessee man
man oh man I'm going Tennessee because
Tennessee is even more southern
Tennessee on Kentucky with a hat oh yeah
bro they got guns they got good whiskey
Tennessee you got Knoxville you got
Nashville Tennessee I've spent some time
in Tennessee I spent time in Virginia -
yeah you went to elementary school -
yeah it's a Virginia remember I believe
Alexander al
Zann drea Virginia is where the CIA has
their headquarters so now we got to take
that into account it's the capital of
the Confederacy I believe is in Virginia
so you know what Virginia I might have
to go Virginia because they're at the
intelligence they already got all the
intelligence the topography of Tennessee
they know everything about it that's
true that they that's true they got all
the books and Virginia also has the most
presidents buried in any graveyard is in
Virginia so they got those presidential
ghosts yes
if somebody's able to arouse the dead
help to enforce the troops they're gonna
have leadership like no other yeah you
got evil cause power and that's
Hollywood scimitar think it's actually
called a Hollywood cemetery can you look
at it yeah I'm going Virginia all day
long yeah you got Alexandria Virginia
you got Department of Defense you got
all kinds of shady [ __ ] that goes on
there man
yeah you got a lot of universities in
Virginia too you got a lot of young
blood you got Radford Virginia Tech so
you got good ideas you got a lot of
brain power in Virginia yeah you have a
lot of brain power brain power and the
CIA yeah Virginia all day but then you
look good rope you go to Tennessee man
my mother used to live in our in
Tennessee and you they got rivers they
have the land they have the I'm gonna
hide you you can get into some guerrilla
warfare in the Blue Hills testing yeah
okay
the smoking mount the Smoky Mountains
you get you get you get in that's from
them Smoky Mountains and here's the
thing damn you're right Hollywood
Cemetery goddamn beautiful Cemetery man
bro it's impressive it's a little bit
now here's the thing Tennessee puts up a
defense they put up a defense you're
living in the woods but you get Virginia
Virginia now Virginia just kind of what
they do
what is when you're in the woods
fighting you got to leave your kids near
your wife behind
they just corral them up well and they
just put him at camp and they say listen
we're not gonna feed him until you guys
come out of the woods that's what they
did in the Boer War the British did to
the Boers did they to the Duchy South
Africa yeah so here's the thing that's
how they that's how you break a
guerrilla resistance yeah with a mega to
the heart
Virginia loses the tent Tennessee
they're looking at the wrong things but
that's between
we choose mm-hmm yeah we there they're
wrong yeah the people are always wrong
and we're here to correct the people
it's not their fault yeah we're here to
correct to pollute people go Virginia
Wow writing it in that's just how it's
done that's government guys you wonder
what government is like okay that's
socialism you all vote for something but
then some fella sitting by an American
flag next to a piece of electricity
tells your nan and that's a typo bang
bang this one's a tough one Alabama
Mississippi Mississippi's got that River
oh yeah I understand and when you got a
river you can move provisions you can
move forces up and down you have to get
that goal form X the Gulf goes right out
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
advantages in Mississippi but they got
to go through Louisiana to get to the
end of the river first of all so they're
gonna have to deal with a little bit of
Louisiana Mississippi you have severe
education issues severe education issues
and it's the fattest state yeah in the
Union that's the poor crime belt yes you
got some fatty pants you got oh we've
got some obesity to say the least say
yourself a lot of good for players but
not as many as they used to you know
Alabama you have Nick Saban first of all
could be the coach of your entire arm
I'm going with Alabama then yeah I'm
going you got Nick Saban you know he's a
field general you you know his strategy
so Nick Saban takes over and and and
you're done yeah now there are more
alligators in Mississippi but that just
means more of your guys are getting
going down yeah you found a sneak around
BAM snack go unless you got malaria when
the whole grid breaks down oh yeah you
know there's more water in Mississippi
so everybody's got malaria you got
malaria Jackson over there to do don't
think I went to middle school with her
hey let's hear we got a white guy
something to say all right yo gang gang
Theo Jordan here just wanted to start by
saying man my own state of Alabama would
most definitely win if there was never a
war to break out between the states
reason being man we got KIV that's
Governor old grandma cooking in the
kitchen she's got that vodka underneath
the counter we got Nick Saban man lookin
really we have some of the hardest
workers you'll ever find in a statement
some of the most down-to-earth people
willing to give you the shirt off their
back but also willing to stand up and
fight for their values but we love our
god we love our guns and we don't drink
beer on Sundays how am i raising that
sweet corn no no we were raised on that
whole milk and that biscuits and gravy
get with it I like that kid American see
that [ __ ] kid yeah air now I love that
boy and that boys right John Nick Saban
I love that kid so he's right that you
want to fight dudes like that and
Alabama yeah no no that's a good kid
Yeah right there but don't push him he's
got his boundaries and he knows exactly
he knows exactly what he's willing to
fight for yeah a man defines himself on
what he's willing to fight for in
Alabama has no problem no problem
establishing what they fight for I'm
going with that kid I'll go give him the
shirt he'll give you the shirt off his
back but don't push him don't take
liberties understand he'll give you off
his back do but if you want a scarf dude
you're gonna get your [ __ ] ass we
don't drink beer on Sundays god bless
that kid good Christian living yeah all
right
that guy's got the Lord his veins in
Mississippi I think just still a little
too much too much of the devil palomero
it is too much the devil a littles to do
this show people some guys you know
think they're still enslaved down there
I bet you most people can't spell
Mississippi down i mississippi no they
make oh I don't know who's that many S's
in peace they made it way too hard [ __ ]
but very good recipes but that kind of
stuff is just gonna get your troops
they'll never make it out of the mess
hall man they're all got diabetes yeah
that's a diabetes about that's that
sugar belt yeah you know a lot of sugar
lizards down there got an old school
money a lot of young people getting on
opioids because the daddy on the cotton
this and that and the kids aren't doing
much a lot of uh you know a lot of their
best assets a lot of times leave to go
to other places to have opportunity
you're right unfortunately and hopefully
that changes and I think it is but not
today it's not Alabama Wow look at that
76 percent Wow I can't leave 24 percent
of people thought Mississippi that's
that education yeah
that's true yeah North Carolina South
Carolina you gotta go South Carolina
more aggressive yeah I mean it's just
more southern I guarantee there see the
floor south you go the more guns there
are that's just a fact
oh yeah a lot of guns in North Carolina
and I love both states
but I'm going South Carolina and I think
right now in North Carolina you got Zion
Williamson over there do you have
University of North Carolina you have
Duke you have Wake Forest you have a
little bit more education but then
they've done that stop to fight they're
more apt to reason that's a but they
might fight more strategically though
now but I went to school in Charleston
South Carolina for a semester and I
hitchhiked up there actually from a
boating regatta down in Biloxi
Mississippi and slept on a man's couch
for a while I almost got arrested
petting a cat on some lady's porch no
yeah and don't do that dude that's when
you're at that [ __ ] moment where
you're like Who am I you know you're
standing outside of a sleeping woman's
window petting a cat yeah that's a
problem that's when you thankfully put
the cat down I [ __ ] left she thought
you were a peeping tom
oh well after that there's not much left
to do except crime that's true man
that's true I didn't know the cat now
you shouldn't have had your pants down
around that's where she probably felt no
I wore two belts when I went over there
just so I'd have to think twice before I
did anything Stan but I'll say this man
South Carolina you have a lot of sailing
and stuff over there you have you have
total access they used to have one of
the largest um indentured servant
markets was right there in Charleston
you have the battery in Charleston if
canons already lining the walls there
you have Clemson you know they pronounce
it with a P in it but it didn't even
have a PA and Clemson but they call it
clumps and yet if you don't say Clemson
they get Pitt they get pissed bro they
do and it doesn't have a letter in it
bro so that's the kind of psychology
you're dealing with yeah I'm going South
Carolina Wow yeah man I'm going South
Carolina Wow this never happened um what
did what did the people say what do you
guys think Nick give any thoughts I mean
I think you just you gave a really
compelling argument I had North Carolina
before but after all that I can't even I
was just thinking about all the colleges
Michael tour and athletes but you got
Michael Jordan you got his blood still
running in the streams over there yeah
he's a shooter Jordan like Artie Lange
said it best about Michael Jordan his
will to win was second and I said if
Michael Jordan had been on a Titanic it
would not have somehow he would have
been plugging holes with his own hands
so yeah so
you know if if if Michael comes back to
to run his army I don't know
yeah because well he bought the
Charlotte Bobcats and they [ __ ] he's
so well - well that's why that's why in
that ship son that's why I'm going South
Carolina all day
I'll go South Carolina - on this woman
with the upset Wow
again people no no she that's northern
elitism right there
it is and you know there's a lot of
Yankees a lot of fancy kids that can't
get into some of these yeah the Ivy
Leaguers they end up in these bootleg
schools pretending that those are Ivy
League UNC is one of them ah you know
God bless the heels my mother went to
Duke and I respect them but and that's
not really one of them but also Cornell
or you know don't put them out or a
University of Indiana with him like
that's a you know not where the Ku Klux
Klan started or there's just other
schools that they use a lot of times you
know right Louisiana Louisiana Louisiana
and Arkansas who stuff with see now
Arden saw again a lot of farming tough
people but Farms get the hills though
you gotta be autumn of the Rocky
Mountain something about Louisiana yeah
Louisiana is home to Nam yeah voodoo I
was about to say I was about to say the
dark arts of Voodoo you got sank what
does it sense I really yeah yeah yeah
and you got voodoo Yeah right and
there's an under tapestry you got rats
you got those new Trejo trees yeah
they're that are African rat they're the
biggest rats in the world there's [ __ ]
in Louisiana you don't even know about
yeah they got every poisonous snake in
the world including Cobras probably dude
they have a frat they can catch a
frisbee Rand that's a new trailer right
there those [ __ ] things and look you
can eat them dude if you want to die I
know you can I heard they're good eat
beaver right I mean look at that [ __ ]
thing I mean here's the thing is the
only place they are up from and yes they
came over on slave ships man it's
fascinating in their French actually
yeah beautiful French rat and it's a
beautiful like nutrious here's the thing
man you got you just gotta go Louie
Louisiana because there there are see
I'll tell you what there's an underworld
in Louisiana - Arkansas doesn't have an
underworld that's true governor Edwards
David Duke
a lot of dirty minds bro and there's
there's like there's like veins under
the seat when you caught it Louisiana
you see Louisiana but there's a there's
a network of is an artery of tunnels
yeah artery of evil yeah let's just an
artery a [ __ ] that gets done on where
you don't see things yeah there's all
kinds of [ __ ] that goes on that you
don't see in Huey Huey P long it was
supposed to be a the next
president-elect possibly was gunned down
in the state capitol man in the sixties
there you have a lot of famous
politicians have gone to jail there for
crimes by the way look at that Wow agree
Louisiana 85 215 Arkansas hasn't been
good since they had norm Richardson
runnin [ __ ] over there you know we'll
wait at least got busted this year over
at Louisiana State University are [ __ ]
bringing him the best illegal players
ever I didn't know that because Arkansas
is one of those states I always forget
about aspect I've been well I say give
it to Palestine man well you know it
wouldn't be a bad idea with it it
wouldn't be a bad idea you know what if
they're not gonna help you over there
we'll help you over here yeah that's a
good point man I like the view oh yeah
they got a lot of tunnels there too all
right well yeah Palestine that does it
for the South Region first round
time for the West Palast Arkansas's
wouldn't it be good mm-hmm but yeah
that's a long name though
all right Oregon Idaho Montana I mean my
dad is the last frontier man Idaho's
great but it's a lot of rich people is
it yeah now people are moving Boise's be
the Sun Valley Boise you got Charlamagne
you got all kinds of places where people
go
Idaho's become the playground for the
rich so Montana still got Cowboys still
got tough people Oregon man you still
have though you got Nike first of all
everyone is gonna be fitted to all that
it's a bunch of white people with bad
tattoos and sensible shoes
Oregon Oregon I mean I mean it's so
liberal and progressive Portland
Portland plus it's always raining in
there depressed yeah some homeless guy
if I almost got falls asleep on you
can't wake them up in Portland it's true
it's so great because it might be
dreaming
yeah so Oregon for me is like a place
that again it's just too liberal yeah
there are people kick your ass in Oregon
I mean yes it's the logging town I mean
a lot of blue-collar dudes but overall
you gotta take into account it's just
too progressive to fight a war because
they might not all agree to fight that's
the problem yeah they'd have sit-ins and
they'd have to deal with their own
[ __ ] protests but they're tough
though logging I mean bro you back in
the day they were tough yeah but now you
have inadvertent logging like your
loggers even if you don't want to be you
won't be having dinner and a [ __ ] log
will just fall right off a mountain roll
right through your kitchen that is true
and that is true but that's that's old
repository from back in the day like
Oregon is basically guys with fancy
beards and waxed mustaches and they're
into beer like the classic good point
that you know they'd have beer tastings
yeah free tastings [ __ ] off yeah every
other beer you need to make a [ __ ]
knife homie all right you're gonna get
your ass beat and that's their always
water log bro but look where they are
though aren't they in the top left yeah
look at Oregon dude it's a lot of
Patagonia models I beat up that whole
stage yeah you could be the second of
your sequel I mean I'm just saying I
mean look at those guys they I don't I
can't hang out with those guys yeah a
lot of glasses a lot of people dressed
like they're looking for gold but not
looking for gold they're just going to
work yeah man with your dumb beard and
your stupid it's all good I'm working I
like it I like Portland it's a cool town
but it's just too waterlogged
I mean Idaho Montana first of all that's
where the war begins and between those
guys because Oregon is just gets
squashed but Montana see both states are
real sunny so they they got a lot of
energy and a lot of vitamin D that's a
good point yeah it's very healthy a
healthy electoral motor
yeah but Idaho it's got too much East
Coast West Coast money hmm
and just too many [ __ ] we're boys I
hate remember Boise State the blue field
yeah you know that guy proposed to his
wife one of their best plays was got
proposed to his wife on the field dude
I've been hunting up in Montana zero
boys for that you've been hunting we're
I'm sorry in Montana and the Missouri
Breaks I've been to Montana three times
that's the last frontier is it Montana
beats the [ __ ] [ __ ]
both those states bro yeah there you not
Montana's the winner there yeah not
everybody hunts everybody's got way more
than one gun and we're not talking about
pistols we're talking about ak-47s we're
talking about ar-15s we're talking about
modified our 1450s
we're talking about every pistol you can
think of and every shotgun you can think
of an every hunting rifle you're talking
about guys who was shooting deer and
everything else through a scope so so
you got snipers in Montana they've taken
out your whole [ __ ] front line and
your command structure that's true from
so far away oh yeah they have scopes
passed down from generation to
generation yeah horoscopes kaleidoscopes
all together bro they'll shoot you when
you're in [ __ ] Idaho yes yes you know
you a [ __ ] bro you'll be filling your
uh your your [ __ ] little mule bag up
a water Scopes Monkey Trial got all of
it man oh brother they'll shoot the
[ __ ] nuts right out of your [ __ ]
body yeah you're done and the Sacko heel
on the way out that's how [ __ ]
capable they are harder sighs what the
people say due to some limitations of
Instagram we don't have a pole for this
one Jesus a night price can only do one
verse one all right Utah Nevada Wyoming
my choice is gonna surprise you guys
okay I'm gonna start with this one so
Utah first of all this is this we're
talking Sun burn we're talking people
that are looking for the Lord we're
talking I want to go back to Idaho
Montana
let's go back there's one little caveat
Idaho grows potatoes potatoes are they
live in the ground what you mean that's
it that's a crop it's hard and destroy
he's a lot of water but that's a crop
that that feeds you now you can live on
cheese and potatoes yeah okay so you can
feed your army yeah but you gotta feed
them potatoes au gratin it's true and
that takes a while to paint so let's go
back let's [ __ ] it with let's stick with
Montana yeah I had I had to bring it up
no you were actually you know what I'll
say this about Idaho as well since you
say that they also have the second
largest they make most of the sugar in
America comes out autumn from beets they
have sugar beets there so you got to
think of the crops I don't know
what's my antenna growing tobacco they
got that one guy smoking in the
commercial Montana you gotta kill your
own game yeah that's a problem it is a
problem dude because I don't look at
food supply oh it's huge what are you
gonna eat okay now what what did I grow
Montana yeah I don't know yeah hey have
these Montana [ __ ] cherries now we'll
say this they have great cherries in
this area so keep you sustained though
but there are Gators - okay taters does
he eat them with the skin they're super
nutritious what is the UH it could go to
population I think you might be right
hold on apples [ __ ] potato okay we
got some stuff we are flax do we yeah we
got beans and potatoes I'm good I'm good
and some game we're good you're gonna
stick with Montana Wow I'm glad though
you brought that up
all right now I don't think you brought
it up like Utah Nevada Wyoming God all
right I'm gonna say this man Nevada has
too much money going around in it to go
easy
Wyoming it's like aren't they just
Montana are they gonna combine with
Montana or some of those people gonna
slip over there Cheyenne Jackson Hole
you got a lot of fancy people moving up
there to ski it's become the new Utah in
a lot of ways like rich people moving
out there hiding it's so cold up there
why oming people say that you know
they're not sure oh yeah you know Nevada
you got a lot of that money now Utah
dude you have people that went there you
got religious people that are motivated
by religion and that is powerful most of
the movements of Mormons in the world
have been religious motivated movements
I think that's a good is thing though
mm-hmm yeah Utah I like what you're
saying with the Mormons they're already
a team but then Nevada does have Las
Vegas and that there's a lot of money
seen a lot Nevada is way wealthier then
I would imagine both states yeah
the Mormons have a lot of money in the
church though how can the Mormons have
banks mm-hmm and the Mormons bro I've
been there Salt Lake City you pass
through the Tabernacle area bro you can
get married
any [ __ ] body broke yeah if you if
you say you're Mormon they're more I've
seen [ __ ] a four year old man you
know what you don't here's the other
thing you don't know about Utah and
Mormons they recruit heavily in Tonga
and Samoa Wow
so you got a shitload of Samoans and
Tongans maybe the toughest people ever
the dark parts baby enjoy that [ __ ]
enjoy fighting those guys Oh enjoy
fighting an army of men and women cuz
Tong and women are stronger than the
average white European man yeah that's a
fact
they'll beat the [ __ ] out of you dude I
saw a tonguing I get hit by a spear bro
and he giggled a little I said it
tickled Tongans are not to be [ __ ]
with they walk around all of them are
way over 220 pounds they can sleep
standing up they're just crazy thick
that's insane bro sometimes at the
airport if their flight gets late you'll
see 60 or 70 of them sleeping in a group
just standing yeah it's absolutely crazy
you gotta be quiet when you go by I'm
obviously not a [ __ ] shear kind look
at that one in four tons and US Coast
Utah I'll tell you wrong hands [ __ ]
down bro religion is not playing bro you
think people aren't gonna [ __ ] go to
bat Utah hands down
Utah hands down good call let's see what
this guy says yeah so Utah cuz you got
the volunteers and not just for fighting
but also for meal prep a large-scale
meal prep you know that the ability to
organize not just gatherings but also
you know any construction projects we
would need to do we could just do
construction on all the roads into Utah
and then known on Utah drivers will be
able to get through it
hiking lots of [ __ ] hiking a very fit
active hunters hunters got the guns know
the terrain so no state terrain would be
in foreign battleground to us sure your
new wide room you could say it's for God
the religious jealousy of that could
rival the Crusades maybe she's thinking
and if the Mormons are in on it then you
know we got the funds so she can gain
ok gang bye bro did you see in the end I
could see her looking out at the just
millions of Mormons in front yeah she
made that video and they march in
soldiers of God
summed it up and you can see she helped
that she blinked twice in a minute and a
half that would then that is a Mormon
woman she's ready to go to beautiful
dark eyes God congratulations good um
it's hard to mention yes on this podcast
no I want to talk about fighter in the
case no I said congratulations oh sorry
yeah he's gonna be here today is he till
he is yeah he looks up to me
mm-hmm there would be no crystal here
without me he's open for me you know
fact and that is a fact dude and some
people have said that now there's a lot
of stuff out there you know that arm you
know different comedians got their vibes
from different people you know dice says
that Sebastian took his style
daliyah took he I gave him his essence
what was well the bravado I can see from
the neck up its you everything about me
he I was his biggest influence and again
yeah then and all that stuff go back
just a just go back in the den alone all
I ask is go back to my early stuff yeah
ten minute podcast before that Alright
fighting a kid all the way back go all
the way back please
but this is heavenly or do you is my
peas my pup yeah I let him out of the
nest and I'm glad he's flying I could
shoot him down anytime I want
yeah but just to understand I'm his
biggest influence at the end of the day
I'm his [ __ ] dad yeah I'm his dad oh
yeah yeah oh yeah you stand me oh I see
it when I think of him I think of him
like soaring in the sky right yeah but
then I think of a man if you look in the
distance of that vision yeah there's a
man on a mountaintop and he has that
thing on his arm with a piece of [ __ ]
meat and the thing see and you
understand that and what you also don't
see is a very thin piece a fishing wire
that's attached to his ankle Jesus
Christ so anytime I want
yank him out his sky when he's soaring
oh it's not a problem for me when he's
out there with his [ __ ] guy a little
anoche that guy that [ __ ] bootlegger
now you know she's not even a tell he's
not Italian he's not fraud oh dude it's
so guys that guys [ __ ] he was a dog
all brown and then returned he was
adopted and returned really yeah
he's I'm not saying anything but a lot
of people are just a dog dr. dan return
yeah you think I'm a bum kid I mean I'm
kind of larvae you get a fake Italian
bro he got to pick his [ __ ] last
thing like ice not Italian not tired
you think that guy's [ __ ] Italian
what no funny Browns a funny comic oh
he's very funny dude but it's secondhand
smoke it's third-hand smoke crystals
your paw and he sees Craig and he sees
no cheese everybody he's like hey okay
guys who are extras in a movie
hey guys who extras in every single
movie ever see what's going on no he's a
hard-working comic Amanda tell you bro I
know she's not a time but he's funny
yeah I want to get him on fire in the
kid I would but he's dead but you know
Chris won't let him go I called him I go
I can't have you on because you know
they're just ratings wise we're with
mid-roll no I love him I want him on you
know I even told him that I can't have
you on I can't look at the same thing my
parents told him that adopted you know I
want her she's funny as [ __ ] well he got
adopted by a family did it still did
some light vaudeville kind of stuff and
he couldn't could hack it oh so he
wasn't good for the circus so back I
knew a Navy SEAL who grew up in the
circus traveling circus Neil's was easy
for me it was grown up in a circus that
was a [ __ ] mm-hmm all right ah two
more two more we're gonna be will be and
we'll shut it down for this first round
man this is absolutely awesome
New Mexico Kansas now I'm gonna be in
Kansas City this weekend that's right as
you mean kids he can start rough
starting Friday Saturday now I'll be at
the Kansas City improv Friday Saturday
now I tell you about my Phil
the next weekend but was sold out and
probably to add a sixth show and I could
tell you about my Calgary shows in the
fourth fifth and sixth yeah I'm not
gonna do that right now but how great is
Calgary then it's fantastic will I be
there of course I will April 4th in you
should now get your tickets it doesn't
matter here's the thing I'm sure will
sell out hurry up
that's not what we're here for it now
I'm gonna say some things about Kansas
hmm I like Kansas Oh tall people all
right you got to see over the wheat man
you can see over the wheat it rains
sideways they got some strong weather oh
yeah hands they call it the [ __ ]
white Vietnam I didn't know that I
didn't know that but it's flat and it's
open now Kansas is great I can't wait to
be in Kansas City yeah a couple things
about New Mexico you need to understand
that Kansas City's a Missouri
it is there are two Kansas cities it's
true Kansas City Kansas Kansas City
Missouri mister you're gonna be I'm not
sure where I'm not sure which one I'm
gonna be in because I went bad on
Missouri so find out where the [ __ ] that
is I apologize to both states damn it
I'm gonna have 15 people in my show and
they're gonna have guns and I'm the best
I'm in Missouri right do bring a gun
meatery yeah yeah so [ __ ] Kansas I'll be
in Missouri now listen New Mexico has a
couple things going for it yeah in
Spanish American War the one thing that
a lot of the Saxon the white American
fighters would always come anna has on
the bravery of the Mexican fighter wow
that's a fact yeah and there's something
in the Mexican blood that they are if
they are a brave hard-working people
alike I mean they you watch them as they
when they box they I talked about this
in my special complicated Apes oh my
bleep god oh mama thought those no it's
easy if I had to fight a man from Mexico
and a man from France and I knew nothing
about either one right law of averages
says to go with Pierre every time right
yeah right so Mexico like when you watch
fight they don't that I don't I've never
seen one I don't think they teach in the
Russian and Mexican school of fighting
they don't teach you how to retreat
you just keep moving forward or so you
got a lot of that in New Mexico
yeah here's the other thing you got in
New Mexico you got I mean I mean come on
think about how many great fighters are
from Mexico of Mexican origin I mean you
know I'm saying like like No
oh yeah I mean Ryan or take I mean it
keeps going it's crazy so look at one I
mean Marquez one of the greatest
fighters of all time
Herrera the assassin Canelo Chavez the
greatest fighters of all I mean and then
forget MMA is crazy
Antonia Oh half the whole immolation
yeah they're all amazing so so so and
you also got one more thing going for
you New Mexico I think a los alamos well
they made that nuclear bomb yeah aliens
came there thank you sir so New Mexico
all [ __ ] day
yeah because also Olmec a lot of
mexicanos make on us and we have a lot
of make on a listeners are going to go
there just because it's called New
Mexico they're gonna get the hats
they're gonna get the 100% looking Yuri
they're gonna go there once Yuri
yeah they you read the aqua with DJ so
you're gonna have a lot of a lot of uh
you know um you got communica a
community yeah how many company like
Papua New Mexico and a lot of Native
Americans that's true a lot of Native
Americans Oh hieroglyphics I think
Pueblo I think you got all kinds of like
different Native Americans and Navajo oh
dude no I don't know a lot of the tribes
there but native Mertilla ho you know
yeah burn a gram they got everybody New
Mexico there you go out there you go see
and you know it but it is it one place
you're still gonna find a lot of hard
workers a lot of white hard workers it
would be Kansas I think unless even the
farms they're going to a lot of Latino
workers they've gone they've gone by
where the factory farm so it's all done
by machine brah so don't worry about
that because I was in the transition man
I used to work on a soybean corn cotton
Milo farm and uh on the Louisiana and
missus
be Delta right oh yeah it's impressive
and um in my summers from high school to
into college and I remember the last
summer that I was there was the first
time that they got a Mexican worker so
it was like you could just start to see
it kind of getting into the area that a
lot of Latinos were coming in Wow and
migrant workers you know you but you
didn't have if the the two the two
summers before they didn't have it right
you know and then and then the third
summer they had this guy named eme and
he was him and he was Jimmy we were sure
Jimmy but Jimmy he wrote it down a
couple times he wasn't even God why you
me Gary I know oh yeah
yaks on view ox only yoga okay we have
the last one Bryan Callen here today in
the first round of the state Wars March
Madness I mean this is a big one
Hawaii's got big strong Hawaiians but
there are also a lot dick addicted to a
lot of sucrose a lot of drugs a lot of
weed over there yeah crystal you gotta
go you gotta go Eliza
there you go Alaska the last frontier
the hardiest [ __ ] on the planet
living below zero imagine they can they
can ride a horse they can they can do
everything dude imagine waking up in the
morning and having to ship yourself out
of your own [ __ ] head when the ice is
I mean you know they know how to skin
they not I get they know how to live off
the land
yeah Alaska crushes Hawaii because
Hawaii is great but you know it's too
much Beach too much you know to easy
right it's gotten to yeah I think at
this point it's gotten too easy they
can't even make their football teams
good but the highest that ever gets to
be is like number 24 or something
Aloha yeah I mean yeah they have it's
hard to play with flour you can't fight
with flowers around your neck dude LA
you can't fight with a
dude impossible ah Alaska you can have
mittens made of your ex-wife and I like
oh yeah we're ex-husband if you got if
the Hawaiians tried to go into Alaska to
take it over it all died Amitabh
it's like gremlins when they hit water
Hawaiians can't handle that kind of cold
they just die right away they first of
all they would even add a dress for it
oh they get off the plane and freeze to
death I mean they'd just be frozen right
there and then they just come out with a
statue they just like to keep them
frozen and have like the Hawaiian Museum
and you just kids from Alaska would walk
through that frozen Museum of like
frozen Hawaii
yeah dude Milo and Oh lilo and stitch is
their big movie Alaska has called the
wild one dude went out there and tried
to read a book and [ __ ] died in a bus
yes he did the Jack London wrote to
build a fire call it a wild Jack London
was a great writer and he didn't even
live in Alaska somebody said he just
read about well he and I made that up
okay yeah he did live in Alaska he lived
on I work on a boat
he's a great [ __ ] writer Deadliest
Catch that's awful where Alaska yeah bro
dude Deadliest Catch
that's an unsafe work environment yeah
not the Google cafeteria because
somebody wrote some stuff about men and
women and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah not the
Oahu [ __ ] mahi grill that is not a
dangerous work environment it's sure
ain't yeah and plus your camouflage into
why you guys pick the worst camouflage
it's the floral the bright colors your
[ __ ] it's like a tropical bird yeah I
want to do a shoot you out of the sky
party you're gonna get shot on the plane
bro they're gonna know you're coming
right now so I think all your hardest
hitters have really probably moved on to
Hawaii Alaska there you go there you go
we have a lot of Alaskan listeners too
actually
we written a lot of video and audio
services from Alaska Wow um so let's uh
and there's the next rounds we'll put
those on the screen get some good ones
okay we did well I think I think we did
well - man very interesting thank you
for the UH for the knowledge man this is
a big second-round matchup California
meet Ana yeah who were some of it was
Callie Montana Texas Virginia
it's gonna be good New Jersey versus
West Virginia you even imagine whoa
Romek it's not aggression it's going to
I don't know that's a [ __ ] tough one
jersey Oklahoma Louisiana a Jersey is
Italian versus redneck that's both the
toughest [ __ ] yeah we're gonna think
about a lot of these video submissions
yes send him videos we don't know if
it'll be Brian here next time we may
have another famous comedian here I love
being here thank you for having me I'm
next door you know where to find me Oh
hear me yeah really
we hear you buddy and you just start a
YouTube channel right Brian yeah Bryan
Callen at YouTube / right youtube.com /
Bryan Callen live yeah youtube.com / -
Bryan Callen and we're gonna give you
this man to take care of yourself as you
move forward you just pissed off a lot
of states so yeah I appreciate that and
get complicated apes you [ __ ] yeah
and I'll put complicated Apes on my
Instagram right now check it out this is
go out today and thank you so much to
the fighter in the kid for always being
so supportive me you guys have been we
wouldn't you're one of our favorites
brother well it's a nice special
let's get that new belt forget that yeah
we're the did you get oh we got it is
coming it's coming
this is good it's coming it's April no
no bro we gotta come what better a belt
in the meantime I start and I'm very
happy was it a vision you had we I think
we had the IRA blacksmith's we got a
banjo banging it out I've had to mine
the gold you know I'm saying the gems
and where's Chris I'm Melea gonna be at
you know those puppies he has on his
Instagram they're not real they bring
him over to his house to use him mm-hmm
and then the lady takes him back chris
is a phony and a racist
oh definitely I don't mean to spread
rumors but yeah holy [ __ ] hold on this
is a knife
yeah check out that blade I love knives
you gotta go get into the box you're
gonna lose to every state fold enough
yeah there's a long as a lap there's a
slash on the side yeah the side folds up
you know
cyfle is I want this knife Oh take it
put it your car very helpful in the car
I carry a knife well now you carry him
tuna dude did I have two knives on me
right now
holy [ __ ] I like this knife but you know
what I want a switchblade
I want two stiletto we'll switch that
[ __ ] out that's a nice little knife -
I'd do some damage with that you can
stab 15 people for it'll [ __ ] be not
that shot long zipper man oh I'll unzip
you oh yeah as I say to a guy go hey bro
you want me to unzip you careful brother
I'll unzip you yeah I play for keeps
because I got you like a dog oh you
wanna know honey you wanna [ __ ] count
your ribs while you die that's it yeah
that's it bro I'll open you up and you
lose hydraulics in eight seconds oh damn
dude look I bought these two little
xylophone mal I did
Marin's podcast I was talking about that
there's this guy who said if I could
start cutting you here in your arms
you're gonna you're gonna lose
hydraulics in about eight seconds Jesus
I was like hydraulics so nice who gave
me this knife Ridge they do they do so
they sponsor us a ridge
I want a knife you got one richer's
really rich I want a knife where I can
like the stilettos for real oh that I
want a bigger one that ritchie valens
well yeah i want to know if i can push
up and be ready for real yeah send me
one that's something you breakout it and
you have a semi one yeah let's eat this
one they might have those I must I'm not
taking this one from maybe I added to
the product line just take that bro you
just [ __ ] told 20 states that there
are [ __ ] all right
and you're going to two of them this
weekend I'll take this Ridge knife I
like this thank you but one thing is
though Kansas City is right there on the
border man you're gonna appeal from both
walks of life can't send this out come
out one and all come out strong yeah you
know I'm saying
oh yeah that's a knife did I keep you
busy with this [ __ ] knife I'll keep a
[ __ ] cat busy with my dick oh you
will but you see what I say is when I
pull out my knife and I go I just start
picking my teeth and I mean picking my
nails like oh yes I am teeth I go just
remember your kung fu is no good here
see what I did you see I went low just
remember
your kung-fu is no good here
that's scary dude did I feel like I'm
gonna now take from mother will be blood
yeah you know I drink a milk shake
yeah I drink your milkshake there's a
different time man would you a sir
what what obviously you're surviving a
lot in this time period but what time
period do you think you could not have
survived well in I mean the the probably
the thing that people don't realize
about most of history is you died of
diseases like the pox the plague
diphtheria malaria Oh all kinds of
diseases so you know you you you and if
you didn't do that you get cut and get
an infection and gets staff and die it
would go septic are they have to you
know people who have a problem with
Western medicine
please look at some old pictures of the
Civil War yeah there were mountains of
amputated legs in hands and feet and and
arms because when you got injured they
had to cut your hand off because it was
gonna go gangrene is gonna kill the rest
of you yes so you had to lose we didn't
come up with with essentially you know
things to dress wounds until world World
War one and after you got you just had
to have it lopped off and we didn't
really have anesthetic
Oh bite down on this [ __ ] on this on
this rag and we're gonna cut your
goddamn leg off that's what would happen
you mean so we owe much to technology
and now we got and look on your kids out
here skating on [ __ ] yeah of water
people who don't vaccinate their kids
man I mean I don't know like if you look
at history forget the science just pick
up a book on literature history yeah
everybody was dying you lost your kids
you buried your kids to shitty diseases
tetanus things that we don't even think
about anymore yeah rusty nail do it you
want to lose your son to a [ __ ] rusty
nail what would had a did you have a
stance on some is severely like
outlandish idea that's the problem
that's what's gonna happen in some of
these cities already is already is it's
already happening
but I mean that's just that's just
ignorance
yeah you know people just don't trust
Big Pharma and I understand that oh you
understand where that comes from but but
you can't get your information off of
youtube and google only yeah leave this
site just listen to scientists
scientists are in the pocket of the
companies sometimes sometimes but when
you wouldn't be massive and what it's
not even that I'm saying forget okay if
you don't want to listen to all the
scientists because I guess they're all
evil and they're all taking money I mean
that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard
but if you don't so you're all your
doctors are wrong all your doctors are
wrong all your science is wrong cool
I'll give that to you you got that ready
now just pick up because you don't do
this I know you don't do this most
people yeah read any good work of
literature any great play I mean any
we're watching people die of like
consumption whatever it might be read
any history book or we're gonna talk to
any historian who doesn't make money
from the pharmaceutical companies right
talk to anybody they will tell you that
disease that disease that we now
vaccinate for words were the leading
causes of death you lost your children
you lost entire groups of people the
Spanish flu killed that that's just a
matter of historical record what are you
talking about yeah smallpox throughout
the world I grew up in those countries
in the seventies I lived there I saw
leprosy with my own eyes you dumb [ __ ]
without tetracyclines without
tetracycline you'd be done I watch
people die of AIDS with my own eyes my
own neighbors my own friends I saw it in
New York every single day Jerry
O'Connell saw it too and then they came
along with protease inhibitors you
[ __ ] idiots so Big Pharma saves lives
as well
I saw what aids did if you want to be an
AIDS denier go ahead the problem is I
start with my own eyes you [ __ ] and now
they're not dying anymore
now AIDS is this manageable or mayor
more manageable than diabetes and the
virus has had the [ __ ] constantly
compromised themselves to it so so much
because of these cocktail drugs thanks
to Big Pharma and science so if that's
the case we know that if you have staff
or mersa then
then go then don't trust Big Pharma yeah
go figure yourself yeah see yourself and
you see weed and honey you dumped [ __ ]
at you [ __ ] see how long you live yeah
but so so it's funny to me that people
they use the technology in their Apple
phones but that's not evil
they don't trust other technologies so
the confirmation it's confirmation bias
yeah you benefit every [ __ ] day from
scientific thinking right you don't you
don't bury your friends or your children
and your and your parents because of
scientific thinking you dumb [ __ ] a
little respect words do I'm not saying
you have to trust Big Pharma I'm not
saying Big Pharma doesn't have profit
motive and greed and I'm not saying
there aren't corrupt people and all
these things and I must say the first
thing I'll do name big farm out yeah I'm
not saying that you should trust your
government I don't write I don't trust a
lot of Big Pharma I understand that but
when you start going against vaccines
across the board your dumbest [ __ ] yeah
and although you're you're you're an
ignorant idiot who knows nothing about
history yeah and if we are addicted we
have a part in that if you're addicted
to some freakin drugs you're the one
that's addicted like sure they're
addictive you got to eat crazy doctors
shouldn't be right in all these
prescriptions but you have a part in
that as well we have a part in that as
well you know as users you know if you
know just because lakeside maple who's
not sponsoring us anymore but who we
still love and it's been a very great
small business just because they keep
making [ __ ] maple you know trail mix
doesn't make them bad people no it
doesn't make them bad me sitting here
[ __ ] trail mix cures smallpox yeah
they could man you never know yeah
Bryan Callen thank you so much you're
special complicated apes is it
complicated always video - no video no
yeah it's doing really well but it's the
best thing I've ever done I think and I
think you'll laugh I think you'll laugh
you know you're you're you're one of the
most entertaining men I know I always
say that I think entertainers are making
a big comeback on stage yeah you know
and you've always been out there but
guys like you Sebastian Maniscalco
people that are actually entertaining
there's something to hear but also
there's something to watch hopefully I
appreciate it that's the truth we'll see
you guys in the future for round 2 of
this past weekend's state Wars March
Madness thank you
gianni Thank You Nick thank you yep stem
cells
alright cutie pies thanks everybody
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake myself
[Music]